dans comment ça va très très bien ce que
0,12 à bord donc laetitia bléger miss
france 2004 vous avez déclenché un gros
scandale laetitia moi qui les défend
chez je sais moi je dire les choses au
départ pas nous avait posé nue dans
playboy nuit mais on voit rien oui
l'intérêt alors c'est vraiment ça
n'appelle pas à billets non je vous pose
nue mais c'est vrai que je cache ma
poitrine je ne montre rien à cette
réalité ce soir c'est pour voir le reste
vous allez poser douze ans d'immunité
pendant que les bail en entrevue
vous avez déclaré des entrevues j'ai
envie de me lâcher j'ai envie de me
lâcher j'ai envie de m'amuser genre
allant des rires
l'argent il me l'a fait sexuellement du
tout c'était lady s'est amusé
non alors on va prendre les choses au
départ parce que c'est moi je suis
quelqu'un de consciencieux un de rochers
tout avait bien commencé le 13 décembre
2003 vous avez été élue miss france en
direct sur tf1 dit il à 50e miss france
en plus dans ce vraiment un symbole
voilà j'ai eu un règne sans problème
fille réservée se souvient laurent
discrète on dirait les murs déjà à
l'époque très très lisse il n'y a pas si
longtemps d'ailleurs en novembre dernier
vous avez déclaré il est évident que si
j'avais posé nue dans entrevue on aurait
vu partout même de fontenay vous avez
beaucoup disaient à l'époque
j'aime mieux ça que de voir défilent
derrière à l'air dans certains magazines
voilà à fond derrière vous ont plu ou
didier geneviève c'est ma seconde maman
franchement vous voulez la guerre mais
voilà c'est quoi c'est la consternation
sur un complot toute façon centre ne
l'ont pas fait je savais qu'elle avait
fans qu'elle allait faire une crise mais
je pensais pas qu'elle allait lancer
cette polémique une polémique aussi
forte pour pour une jeune fille qui se
dénude à peine alors qu'elle est chaud
c'est mon plus grand lui viendra
attendait cela
d'abord on m'écoute auditoire est en
écoute on y viendra parce que c'est pas
réglé un don vous disiez j'aime bien
c'est ma seconde maman de pêche et la
saignée et pour colère là javier vous
l'aimiez beaucoup dit il a toujours le
mot pour rire
c'est vrai que les dents
ces gens qu'il va monter sur scène y
croient qu'ils bossent sur un running
man et la honte c'est où vous aviez donc
xavier il a toujours le mot pour rire
j'aime bien dîné avec lui enfin c'est
vrai qu'on est j'ai eu l'occasion dignac
lui ses enfants et il est très bien mais
c'est quelqu'un de très bien monter vos
valises parce qu'il a refusé de porter
les valises de sophie thalmann
abondamment normand il était toujours
très serviable toujours très bas pas
tout allait bien vous étiez la miss
france modèle 1 elodie gossuin par
exemple en parlant d'elle vous disiez je
les aime beaucoup mais j'aurais pas fait
la ferme
j'ai dit ça mais en fait ça vous a pas
empêché de faire la première compagnie
va également mais je suis d'accord la
fille d accord mais c'est vrai que en
fait pendant un an
c'est vrai qu'on est sous l'emprise de
jeunes gagnent on vit avec elle en est
avec elle non enfin il paraît que nous
en sus dans une secte là mais les
interviews les vl était à côté de moi
moi je voulais voulait surtout pas
souhaité passer des bons moments avec
elle voulait surtout pas connu de
problèmes ensemble donc c'est vrai que
j'ai dix jours après que la ferme la
ferme n'aurait peut-être pas fait ma
première compagnie ce qui me plaisent en
1ère compagnie c'est lé défi sportif
cette baroudeuse c'est bien aussi aller
aux chiottes
mettant compagnie simple et vert parce
qu'avant d'être enfermé six militaires
oui pourquoi pour l'éliminer aussi vite
parce que justement je suis pas
caractériel parce que si j'ai envie de
pleurer je préfère le garder en moi que
l'extérioriser à l'époque de se dénuder
j'étais peut-être un peu trop lisse oui
c'est vrai que j'aime changer dans les
toilettes parce que je voulais rien
montré que j'avais des petits boxeurs
aux électeurs de rien montrer parce que
ce qu'on a vu dans playboy obama oui
mais en même temps c'est est reçue fict
oui voilà vous pouvez l'imaginer en fait
vous imaginez mais vous voyez pas revoir
et c'est là après la première compagnie
que vous décidez laetitia de poser nue
pour playboy sécurité qui ont été forcée
de poser à billes et l'anglais déjà j'ai
la chance de ne pas être complètement nu
enfin je suis nîmes on le voit rien
généralement les six à son but et
d'écarter les jambes étaient en
maintenance à l'examen médical
la palabre aussi c'est autre chose en
libye
c'est pas des photos là on a dit que
c'était des photos licencieuses
mais franchement licencieuse veut dire
sans charge de la pudeur vous avec des
fois quand on montre rien ça peut être
plus suggestifs quand on est
complètement nue laetitia voulait pas
qu'on mette un point pourquoi à lévis
montrez moi je les trouve très bon côté
maintenant si j'avais su qu pour du gel
douche ce que j'aurais dû plus longue de
londres plus mais c'est vrai on descend
dans le sud sur la plage les filles on
les voit on voit leur poitrine
on la voit pas façon bien alors vous
avez déclaré je pose nue j'ose me
montrait donc j'existe ça que maintenant
il faut six mois là il faut se montrer
nue pour exister pas ça c'est que en
fait on disait que j'étais lice mais en
fait c'est vrai que miss france on
rentre un peu dans un moule la jeune
fille parfaite saine de corps et
d'esprit
d'après geneviève j'ai très bien
représentée très très bien oui oui vous
avez un ring formidable non mais c'est
vrai geneviève était là m'a parlé ici
elle était ravie de vous c'est abedi
viendra cette photo ça t'a fait du bien
de faire ça m'a fait du bien mais c'est
que
c'est vrai qu'avant laetitia bléger
oblige initiative je fais de deux
couvertures d'entrée plus elle a été
fait c'est ça dépend ce qui montre
d'autre truc c'est que maintenant dans
les casernes dans les camions dans les
poids lourds il ya des photos de vous et
toute sa vie ça pour moi je suis pas tu
pas complètement nue je cache ma
poitrine et j'ai un bac
non c'est très bien a bien roulé mme de
fontenay évidemment est consterné et
intérêts elle a parlé d' incroyable
dérapages laurent quand tu connais une
vieille maison très clair je vais
d'aller là beaucoup bouleversé et choqué
n'a fait des photos pour montrer qu elle
aussi pour les boutons ne sont pas
sortis
vraiment rien mais son chapeau haut de
forme et a dit que vous aviez posé à
côté de bonnes femmes aux cuisses
écartées
non mais c'est la vérité et je peux
comprendre que les personnes fans des
miss france soient choqués de voir
passer de miss france à playboy
elle a dit à toute l'alsace vous rendez
compte 1000 cases à sa poésie dans
playboy donc en fait tous les alsaciens
étaient un peu choqués sur le coup mais
en fait quand ils ont acheté le magazine
ils ont rayé ils ont dit non mais y'a
rien et c'est un aux danses et c'est pas
licencieux voilà en tous les cas d'après
madame de fontenay d'après geneviève
plus est sous domination rend pas aussi
de votre agent vous êtes gourou teasé
salivant g20 comme par une secte par m
votre agence et corinne le chevalier qui
a dû travailler en toute impunité
grâce à moi et laeticia devenir riche
voilà et qu'elle est dit comme ça mais
on va lui demander
concernant karim chevalier c'est donc la
jambe
laetitia bléger est donc vous avez vu
c'est un scandale national évidemment
tout le monde en parle c'est le cas de
le dire
donc vous madame de fontenay vous accuse
d'être une sorte de gourou d'avoir
enfermé laëtitia dans une dans une secte
mais j'ai plutôt l'impression de l'avoir
libéré de quelque chose c'est
l'impression d'avoir libéré une jeune
femme qui était dans un moule comme
toutes les miss sont dans un moule même
moule depuis des années et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la jeune femme qu'on voit
c'est laetitia donc moi j'étais plutôt
l'impression de l'avoir libéré et quand
vous dites grâce à moi elles sont rares
et madame de fontenay l'a rendu célèbre
par ses ouailles
je crois que madame de fontenay l'a
rendue célèbre
ensuite on a eu une mise de plus les
gens ne savaient pas qu'ils étaient
laetitia bléger et maintenant alors je
crois que si j'avais voulu monter un
plan médiatique je n'aurais pas eu
l'idée de faire quelque chose d'aussi
énorme et c'est vrai je pense que là
maintenant on va appeler geneviève de
fontenay
soit c'est l'heure où elle se fait sa
couleur tu confonds oui je ne suis pas
là pour l'instant mais c'est aussi votre
nom je vous rappellerai dès que possible
à bientôt et merci à la fin de votre
message il vous souhaitez le modifier
catéchèse
sinon accroché madame de fontenay
bonsoir comme il le chevalier en direct
chez notre ami ardisson je voulais vous
souhaiter un très bel été vous dire que
laetitia et moi vous remercions de cette
chance incroyable que vous nous avez
offert de devenir célèbre en 24 heures
ça fait dix ans que je fais ce métier et
d'un seul coup tout paris a mon numéro
de téléphone
je vous souhaite un merveilleux et et je
mets un cierge chaque soir à la vierge
en vous hu
button s'est pas bien toi qui est
catholique c'est pas bien on voit pas un
cierge à la vierge je veux dire est ce
vrai on comprend mieux le paquet pas
réagi elle en est revenue au pape
non ça m'a choqué tous les cas merci
d'avoir été avec corinne merci beaucoup
elle va faire de boeing star c'est ce
que j'espère mais maintenant ouvert à
pas pourquoi pas g enfin peu plus au nom
non là c'est l'événement est cool mais
ça c'est quoi c'est ça qu'est ce que
c'est que ça et alors laëtitia a été
sanctionné par le comité miss france
vous est interdite des chats et de
couronnes 6 mois voilà ce qu'explique
celles ci n'ont pas déjà râler quoi
comme barclays la red
j'étais miss france 2004 mais en 2005
ouais mais là j'aurais pu la mettre
encore pas de nous on n'aime pas tous
les jours dans la rue avec un bon c'est
pas contractuel non non non je la
portais pour les manifestations l'année
avec quelques galettes prévus qui ont
été annulés maintenant mais c'est ma
première dauphine messi qui va me
remplissent alors aussi son petit fils
mobile à remplacer nos miss bourgogne
indochine ouais on n'a pas assez de
dauphine d'ailleurs alors vous risquez
gros seins
vous pouviez être obligé de rendre le
titre est de rembourser les cadeaux
grenon et toutes les rues y est content
filet dans la combine dans les ports et
les fromages et les routes bleues les
banderilles en route s'il faut les
rendre dans la voiture non je pense pas
que j'aurai tout vivre en la voiture
l'ordinateur mais en fait c'est des lois
pour ses trucs de miss france présente
n'a pas le droit d'être saoul
oui t'as pas droit d'être nu et tata pas
le droit de fumée de cigarette en public
remonte en vie je fume après
l'éclatement bourg était morte
bien sûr bien sûr et les garçons se
passe comment c'est interdit d'avoir des
relations avec des garçons
billets en vente après ce que l'année
dernière j'avais présenté au public
joubert
oui on en huit mois le patineur brian
joubert qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit c'est
brian joubert qui n'est bien le comité
tu es très content puisque 100 sportifs
quelqu'un au sein du corps et d'esprit
ben voilà comme quoi les gens peuvent se
tromper en fait il a utilisé votre
notoriété en revendre de la drogue
il a utilisé votre notoriété
brian joubert jeu commettant de plus à
m'apercevoir pourquoi parce que il était
quand même déjà champion d'europe où ils
avaient besoin de vous pourquoi ben
c'est ce que vous avez dit pour faire
croire qu'il sortait avec des filles qui
a c'est qu'entre brian et moi c'est
j'étais amoureuse au lit je veux dire je
râle au bout du monde devrait tout
plaquer pour lui et je le suivis partout
et quand je retrouvais se faisait manger
des pizzas et des glaces et c'était une
petite promenade d'amitié voilà ce que
ça il n'y avait pas de relation
charnelle mais quid jambon jambon
fromage non mais si ça comme ça s'est
très bien passé de cet incident qui se
serait passé tout à fond vous l'aimiez
plus que ce que me disais mais je pense
me met vraiment en tous les cas quand
vous êtes rentré de guyane il n'est même
pas venu vous chercher à l'aéroport
tu ferais ça toi oui vous l'avez virer
ne faisait pas de virer je lui ai dit
que voilà ce que les pizzas au bout d'un
moment un nom j'ai dit qu'il fallait que
j'avance que notre relation moi me
faisant régresser plus qu'autre chose et
votre histoire
voilà ta patrie
ça
autant bien
alors maintenant elle mondiale est avec
fougue les tu te souviens de 32 les
frank delay non la mauvaise tête 32 les
laurent franck delay toubitri à je
connais pas les noms de famille oui
philippe adel et franck oui
non mais je connais les prénoms il est
aidé en tête c'est en guyane que ça
c'est fait alors non après la guyane
justement avant et même moi j'étais pas
au courant de faits s'ils étaient avérés
contraire un jour il était surprenant
alors il est très sympa fond il est très
sympa là il est un petit peu de crise
parce qu'il va compter sa femme et ses
deux enfants avant vous et je vous mets
pas ça sur le dos les arrondis je serai
en gardant le permet les gens pour des
cons il faut aller à vélo en garde
alternée les enfants c'est ça mais c'est
pas pour vous qu'il a quitté sa femme je
tiens à le dire quand même que les gens
ne pensent pas que vous soyez que
briseuse de ménage ne pouvait la
souffrance dans la souffrance ou brian
joubert lui sa façon il a déclaré frank
de l'équidé bas pour mariage pas du tout
un va lui pas du tout vie mais pour les
jeunes et brian joubert l'ehpad bedjaoui
lie avec la pizza
violent parlé un petit peu de votre
avenir maintenant laetitia vous avez
déclaré
alors elle les deux hypothèses qui sont
voilà qu'on pas grand chose à voir l'une
avec l'autre mais pourquoi pas je me
verrais bien égérie d'une marque de
cosmétiques falaise ou ouvrir un salon
de thé à colmar en fait ya c'est que
j'adore le mieux la photo j'adore posé
devant un photographe poser pour des
grands photographes et avant d'être miss
france en fait quand j'étais miss france
j'étais très nostalgique de ma région et
je voulais rentrer en alsace parce que
j'avais mes proches m'ont jamais mes
proches là bas mon copain à l'époque
vivait encore en alsace et après se
disait après miss france j'ai économisé
l'argent et douvrin sa montée et
maintenant je me dis ben je suis jeune
j'ai 24 ans j'ai le temps pour faire ça
quand même pas oui nous allons tenter
d'ouvrir et quand vous serez plus âgés
votre agent d'affaires de winstar
peut-être mais inverse
mais il